where do you go to you wake up on a
morning it's cold it's wet it's dark
you've got no cartilage in your knee
you've got your shorts whatever it is
that's the issue today keep talking
you've got these problems I need you to
keep talking about what you were just
saying it's warm on the couch your
misses say stay in bed you're cycling
over can I know every mother ain't gonna
do what I'm gonna do so this is how you
leveled up I know there's a whole bunch
of people with that right there that
fires me up that makes me happy what you
just said that brings joy to my life
right there because I know there's so
many people that have the ability and
just refuse to get off that couch